taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
i taste buddies it's the taste buds
podcast
that's sal that show and we're here to
talk food today
as we always are uh hot
hot hot debate today
hot debate first
versus burgers versus tacos
we talked about this people have been
calling for tacos to fight somebody
now originally we had burgers up against
hot dogs uh
i thought burgers would have taken that
and probably
we held on it and we were trying to
think of what what the matchup would be
versus tacos we named a few things
one thing that came up was pizza but i i
really don't know if
anything will ever beat pizza so we have
to figure it out
maybe maybe burgers might be would go up
against pizza it's a tough comparison
see i i
i think this is such a great match
because you brought up burgers to me
because you said you want to take
tacos well because when we talked about
burgers versus hot dogs yeah
we already argued bacon versus sausage i
felt like we were going to start the
traipse into similar territory
sausage with the hot dogs uh
and i think uh the reason i really like
the idea of burgers versus tacos so much
is because the taco is the burger of
mexico
and the burger is the burger of the
america yeah you know
yeah and and now uh tacos
are i mean they've always been i mean i
would assume for the last
60 or 70 years have been pretty
prevalent in american cuisine
but they're they're really everywhere
now you know like
look and tacos
this is a great matchup because you're
talking meat cheese
veggies right yeah different seasonings
different sauces
different casings but they're
they're they're similar enough that you
got to think dude when you're in the
mood you got to think like am i
do i want a cheeseburger i want a taco
i don't know if i'm thinking of those in
the same breath yes they're both chopped
meat that contain probably lettuce
tomato and cheese
and some type of outer shell or bun if
you will yeah
um and a dressing but i think tacos are
beloved and i love them i gotta be in
the mood for like a fish taco
i like a beef taco i like a steak taco
like a chicken taco it's really great i
like a hard shell like a soft shell
i mean you have a lot of
pluses for you on the taco side sure i'm
not going to say that you don't because
you do
and believe it or not you do we didn't
even say who's taking what yet
well you're talking like that i said i
said you said you wanted to take taco
oh i did i said you wanted to i didn't
hear you downstairs because we were
trying to decide what taco should go
because we knew we wanted tacos in the
episode yeah and we said what should it
go up against i'm like i really don't
know it's gotta be
a powerhouse though you brought up
burgers and i said
and includes cheeseburgers burgers tacos
and uh you said burgers and i said are
you sure you want burgers to go against
tacos because i feel like burgers
would be a natural favorite there well
uh
you know a white privileged male would
think that
so so is that both of us or no it's just
you
okay no no that's you why is that
because you're a team burger
okay and you're also a white privileged
male well i'm half hispanic
okay then you're then you're also you're
also a sellout
[Laughter]
but what are you i'm mostly what are you
that's not how we ask it these days what
is this guy uh
i'm mostly egyptian and i'm also middle
eastern right
so you you have but you but you but you
play white
on tv you play white no i don't i don't
mean you play white i mean you appear
white
oh that's real nice i'm sure you're
reaping white privilege left and right
on your egyptian shoulders though that's
real nice
hispanic i mean but i play white i look
white you know my name's sal i
like italian white like i look like a
caucasian i should say as
i believe you do too you got you have a
little flair in you
i don't think you have you have a little
bit of like um
you have a little bit of um uh what's
the word i'm looking for
um wow i'm really blanking on this word
i don't know you but choose your words
carefully we're on thin ice right now no
no no no exotic exotic you have a little
bit of an exotic look too
like it's a little bit like not straight
i like to think it's an erotic look
personally erotic exotic things that's
that's kind of how i throw down
yeah but uh yeah but but but you're
you're not gonna attach me being white
well i was i was dead serious when i
said it yeah and uh i'm glad you're
taking it so literally well that's what
everyone does now
but there is no there's nothing but
literally yeah we have we have there is
nothing we have funnier taste buds
so so your your team you're regardless
of your racial preferences your team
hamburgers
and i and i also get what you're saying
you are um
you are uh um what's the word when you
take someone else's
appropriation you're appropriating your
culture you're appropriating
tacos though yeah for you to yourself
from you
yeah yeah so we both there's racialness
all over this one we're
we're we're crisscrossing over the
german that created the burger
right is it a hamburger right that's why
it's like i think so right
apparently the green affectionately
known as hamburger charlie
apparently squashed a beef meatball hold
on it's not at all
between slices of bread oh this was in
wisconsin
uh so his customers could walk around
eating
a concoction he claimed was the first
hamburger but is it true
now here's history of the burger from
ancient rome oh so i was way off with
germany
you know i don't think it matters where
the actual burger came from
because underneath pizza
and sandwich which i think burger is a
form of a sandwich
i don't think that anything's ever gonna
be a burger or cheese cheeseburger i
should say i just don't think
i think it is like well we're gonna make
a list of the top like
five most popular foods in the world
maybe first or the united states
certainly
pizzas on it burgers are on it tacos
might be honest sure
but you really picked first of all i'm
not letting you slide with saying a
hamburger is a form of a sandwich
you're not i'm not letting you drift
so is a soft taco in in essence but
that's not what we're talking about
we're talking about two very
when you want a sandwich you do not want
a cheeseburger when you want a
cheeseburger
i'm not i'm not a signing a hamburger or
burger for short is a sandwich
consisting of
one or more cooked patties of ground
meat usually does anything make you more
mad than when somebody serves you a
hamburger on toast
i mean it makes me sick to my stomach
but don't worry i don't need to assign a
sandwich to burger all i'm saying is
that like
it it's i mean like just the word
sandwich
in general is as like as big to me as
burger or pizza sandwich
so i just think so is taco i think
taco's there but i
sandwich uh an item of food she saw a
few pieces of bread with meat cheese
or other fillings between them eaten as
a light meal bread is made from wheat
soy soft tacos
tacos equal sandwich yeah all right so
fine they're two forms of sandwiches
all right and i'm the sandwich king of
new york i don't know if you've heard
oh oh i have heard yeah yeah i have
heard yeah yeah so
look i almost i almost feel like as good
as tacos are
like you have taco night i get it
everyone's like oh we're doing tacos
it's the most fun thing you could ever
do just to buy that build ortega kit
or the old el paso kit yeah or the old
taco bell kit yeah
and you go home kits yeah and you make
and you make the thing up with the
seasoning packet
it's fun and you shred the cheese and
the lettuce i even tried the lettuce
i mean it's it's great before you go to
dish and you get the soft
uh um uh uh what are they what are those
mission uh the soft corn tortillas yeah
and then you you
saute up some you know meat shredded
whatever taco beef taco fish taco
chicken taco
tofu taco so on and so forth tacos are
amazing cactus taco
sure i think tacos are different i think
they're fun to make
i think everyone loves a good taco night
i think people like mexican i think
mexican
cuisine is in uh is in people's rotation
uh culturally
pretty popular taco taco taco taco
taco taco choco taco back to ice cream
yeah it's an ice cream taco yeah i i
like i don't have i don't really have
many strikes against the taco
so much as i can just state that the
king
of this argument is a burger
cheeseburger in my opinion
and i think that okay explain to me why
i almost don't even have to like
go into why cheeseburgers are so amazing
oh my god
i mean i really don't think but but tell
them talk about yourself
we don't know if they saw that one yet a
burger is have you learned yet from the
mistakes i don't know i said
i said that uh what's that we don't know
if they saw the ice cream restaurants
episode yet no i'm not saying the winner
on no winner i know but you're saying
you talked about this on the other
episode they're going to be sitting home
what are you talking about
they haven't seen anything they don't
they they wouldn't be able to they
didn't they wouldn't be able to grasp it
from me saying you talked about ice
cream shops on the other episode right
listen
americans americans love both hamburgers
and tacos
like a lot in fact all right i don't
need to hype i don't need your
extra like okay like a lot yeah okay in
fact nashville just just report the
facts
in fact nationaltacoday.com that's a
website i'm on a lot
it says 4.5 billion tacos come to about
775 million pounds as much as the weight
of two empire state buildings
so here's what we know so far americans
typically eat more hamburgers and tacos
okay
i would i would imagine that americans
probably do eat more tacos i mean
sorry more hamburgers they do uh in a
year than than tacos
but let's get down to the brass tacks of
this thing
why do you think a burger is better than
a taco because i'm prepared to tell you
why i think of tacos well
i'll tell you one other thing on tacos
and i'll move on because i'm not trying
to
i am a sour cream freak that's what they
call me sometimes in the streets
okay i love sour cream you can't put it
on a burger
yes you can i mean you could have it
whoever had to as a matter of fact i
i feel like i could do a top they have
pizza burgers mushroom burgers
okay blue cheese and bacon burgers i
feel like i could see a taco burger on a
menu
no problem all the time yeah that's a
california burger but sure
but i would put i would put sour cream
on a burger and a heartbeat it's the
same exact concept
okay so i asked you again burgers why
yeah i think a burger is
as apple pie as americana as apple pie
we get that i just said it was invented
in germany to start which was a big faux
pas on my part
right but i mean the burger the burger
shop
is i mean burger fries coca-cola burger
fries shake
diner americana cheeseburger summer
fourth of july okay barbecues what's the
number one thing maybe
a lot of images give me a lot of corn on
the cob what's the number one what's the
number one truck
on the street taco truck but my point is
is you give me a lot of imagery
tell me let's get down to the food and
the taste you tell me what makes a
burger so great
a beautifully seasoned delicious juicy
cheeseburger piping hot with some great
grease in there
with some flame broils on it with a
beautiful piece of
melted cheese in the middle of melting
with some crisp lettuce tomato and a
nice
bun brioche sesame seed put a little
ketchup on there
okay it's combinations of flavors that
like are so amazing together like
your classic cheeseburger i mean again
you could say
you know bacon blue cheese you could say
swiss mushroom onion you could say a
pizza burger you could say a california
burger
you could say you know a messy greasy
chopped up chopped meat burger you could
say
all everything you want but the classic
cheeseburger american cheese
not even cheddar with lettuce tomato
onion on a bun
it's like not too many
things go together in that way every
single one of those ingredients
goes with each other you get crispiness
from the onion
you get this like cold from the tomato
and
you get crispy from the lettuce and then
just the melted cheese and the beef like
it just
it's hot it's cold it's crispy it's not
the bread it's
you throw some butter on that bread
maybe too i could say
that's one of the best burgers i've ever
had
the best burger i've ever had i'm pretty
sure i could say this
is the red hook tavern in brooklyn okay
they make a burger and i'll pay it i
mean it's insane it's like 26 bucks for
the burger
it is a beautifully toasted like brioche
bun with
one piece of raw griddled onion on the
bottom that's the size of the whole
patty
with a beautifully i mean a really nice
stick we're not overdoing it
but a really nice patty and then melted
cheese it's simple
you bite into it they put butter on the
bun it is
one of the tastiest things i've ever had
in my life it blows away any taco i've
ever had
all right i like tacos i think i think
it's wrong you get a really nice
some places do mexican really well like
and they'll like some menus have like
you know when they like i just i just
had uh fish tacos on a menu the other
day and they were like amazing
but the point is is just that tacos will
never
not at least here in the united states i
don't think they're ever going to beat
in a
head-to-head match what are you talking
about not
here in the united states what are you
talking about well i mean like if you
said to me
if you go to their their in their
natural culture
you go to mexico and say tacos vs
burgers tacos is gonna win
that's where they come from but you know
i'm just saying here
where i'm sure we have a lot more we put
the polls up on twitter a lot more the
people that know us know
us from the united states so i'm just
saying like if it was like
a mexican audience i think tacos would
have a chance but i think
in a general sense burgers versus tacos
and we're polling people
in the united states i think burgers is
gonna win i think burgers is attached
like i said i think it's americana as
apple pie
it's and that's that's when you cut me
off i was saying
when did i cut you've been talking for
five minutes straight i don't know what
i was saying i was trying to say like i
was trying to say like
fourth of july americana this summer you
know grills
cookouts like things like that and you
said all right you said you're saying a
lot about today
it's a lot of imagery you you you you're
basically
you're attaching nationalism to your
food product right now
you're talking about the idea that uh
that because you know no no no i'm
saying there's there's there's people
grow up and they
and they they they attach food to memory
and there's nothing i attach tacos to
memory
yeah i'm just saying but i think more
commonly people are going to attach that
that does
but that doesn't mean it's a better food
i'm still asking you
i asked you and you said i could eat a
burger way more frequently than i could
have tacos
i understand that in this country the
united states of america
these united states that there's
probably more
fond memories about burgers because it's
more of an indigenous food to us sure
than tacos are or even spaghetti or
whatever
apple pie killed me however however
that does not mean that people don't
have memories attached
to taco but that also means more
importantly that does not mean it's a
better food
now i will say this encounter argument
everything you said every attribute you
said about the cheeseburger
i would say about the taco and i would
say holds even better in a taco
i would say the beauty of a taco is the
hard shell
does not get soggy the meat though not
if you do it right
not if you do it right how do you do it
right once you put once you put cream in
the glock
once you put in the actual chopped meat
and the oil starts to get on the bottom
because if you if you if you properly
drain your taco meat and you cook it
properly it doesn't make your
uh shell oily okay that's that's just
how it's great it says it right on the
packet i mean this isn't you know
no problem the uh i mean and also you're
talking about like the at home and i i
don't
i don't disparage them because that's
how i had them growing up and that's
still how i order them today
i when i when i think of taco i do think
of like taco night at home more than i
think of like the taco bell that's what
i'm talking about but you got del taco
taco bell baja fresh
moes you can i i i gotta can i finish my
corn but if i even
begin okay i finished i even begin with
burger restaurants you're gonna talk
longer
to fast casual from diners to gourmet
burgers i love how suddenly now that
counts i love how suddenly now the the
chain restaurants count for his argument
all right i'm only using it because you
used it in your argument
first i understand but there are taco
restaurants
i know yes i mean maybe there aren't as
many in this
caminos i know there's mexicans in this
grand racist country that you love so
much
perhaps there aren't as many taco
restaurants as there should be so
burger joints the burgers you want
the burger is big the burger is the
whole menu let me look at something like
in and out or something like
you know five guys or or or or um
shake shake that's not true you got you
got burger fries onion rings but
it's a bird the whole place is a burger
joint you don't you go to
fast mexican fast casual mexican or
upscale mexican no it's not just tacos
taco truck it's mexican food because
there's a million other things you can
do with what i'm saying the burger
is the star it's a burger joint it's a
burger spot it's a burger and a taco is
the star too
no you got burritos enchiladas
every place you just named every you
said in and out what were the other ones
well i went from i could go fast
five guys says other stuff besides
burgers what was the third one though
you said five
shake shack shake shack has chicken they
have chicken nuggets they have other
stuff
there the only one that does shack is a
burger joint though
well i think they would argue with you
on that that they also have
shakes and onion rings and chicken and
chicken nuggets and all kinds of things
and chicken sandwiches that they
prominently advertise
now i would say this i would say this
sal if you could look at me
i would say this i would say this
you uh uh well say it then in and out
you will say this five times in and out
burger
i don't want to get off an in-n-out
burger this is not the point the point
is this i still haven't made my point i
still haven't made my point
please joe everyone's waiting hot taco
meat in a shell that shell doesn't get
soggy the way a burger bun does the
cheese
now you got to let me make this point
i've been trying to make this point for
you you got to let people
you also not made it when i haven't said
a peep no you talk so much more than i
did taco's right the shell doesn't get
uh messy yes and then you said
but if you do it right doesn't get messy
like burgers do well what if you do the
burger right
a burger bun gets soggy no matter what
no matter what
yes continue thank you i like
that thank you i love what he does he
talks the way he does thank you okay
a burger bun gets soggy okay you made
yourself no matter what you made your
point
i will now make mine okay
not if you do it right no soggy not if
you do it right
no all the time name me one burger
bun that will not get soggy if it sits
there name me one
maybe one i i you want a bun what do you
mean
name you a burger bun okay okay one bun
what did i name you a burger bun
you know exactly my point the point was
nice toasted sesame
burgers the point with burgers is for
them to be greasy
they're supposed to be greasy they're
supposed to bite in and have juice
stream out of it that's part of the
burger experience when you cook a burger
on the grill uh a friend of mine once
told me you're not supposed to press
down on it with the spatula
because that puts all the grease out
with taco meat it is not the same thing
it is a different consistency you're
supposed to drain it you're supposed to
get the oil and stuff out of it
it's a different thing so when you make
tacos the right way
your meat is not oily it does not soggy
up the
shell and now so now you have a hard
shell that is room temperature
or maybe even warm with some hot meat in
it on top of that me
you have some cheese that gets half
melted and says half
cool right because the meat doesn't
fully melt it and then your produce
stays
completely cold and completely crisp on
the top produce
yeah the lettuce and tomato okay okay
so i think everything you love about a
cheeseburger
is done better in a taco
and then on top of it a taco because of
the way it's seasoned
the meata season can hold its own
without any sauce if you wanted to
whereas a burger you kind of need
ketchup and mustard or something you
don't really
you eat a cheeseburger just meat and
cheese you're full of [ __ ]
i put ketchup on it because i prefer it
but i see people not eating not eating
look i i've seen it too i also see
people that don't don't run the whole
garden at the taco either they don't run
the whole fixings bar
some people like pass on the black
olives how strong the taco is versus the
burger a traditional taco
is literally meat onion cilantro
on a corn soft tortilla there is nothing
to do with that
because that's how strong the taco is
seasoning wise
meat wise flavor-wise a burger i mean
come on dude
burger first was meat on bread no i'm
saying you still
when you go to a traditional taco stand
now that's how it's served and it's
awesome still
if you go to a burger place and they
forget the mustard the ketchup the mayo
the pickles you're like
your argument is if you go to the place
and they forget the ingredients
yeah and it sucks is what i'm saying i
should have clarified what i'm speaking
i'm just thinking about a fully formed
burger
i'm saying it sucks i'm saying you
nobody's assuming that when you buy
somebody goes give me a burger on a roll
and that's it nobody does that
why because it's ground meat on a roll
and it sucks
that's my point burger needs hamburgers
on a roll the reason there's a fixings
bar at the
at the burger place now you shoot
yourself with the food
how many minutes are we in he called he
called the burger has a fixin's bar taco
you even
flubbed and you you said taco that's not
good burger is a fixin's bar there's a
taco fiction
tacos where tacos have fixin's balls
tell me anytime you even at home if you
if you're making a taco there's 10 bowls
on the table with all this i'm not
saying i'm not listen to me i'm not
saying they're i'm not saying you don't
use this where's the burger fixings bar
roy rogers my friend oh my god you
picked the one place that has
a fixings
macaroni salad no it was so you could
dress up your burger
buddy if i'm thinking fixin's bar i'm
thinking tacos i'm not
let me tell you a thinking story that
our good friend jay oakerson told me the
other day when i co-hosted
the bonfire radio show with please pray
tell me
he told me a chipotle no no that's not a
fixings bar though i mean it's it's ten
ingredients and pans that you have to
pull from my point is
this though sal my point is this that's
a thing
saying would you like these things on
your taco you can have them however
if you took the meat out of that thing
and put it in a bowl and ate it plain
it would be delicious if you took a raw
hamburger and threw it on the plate
you go this sucks it needs salt it needs
ketchup
i need potatoes i need something with
this no one believes that you're
heating up unseasoned ground beef like
you're claiming i would like you
i would like to shall be seasoned i
would like just like a taco
will be seasoned if you think you think
it's kind of you like cheese and ketchup
do you think it doesn't you don't put it
on you think it's making it like the
birthday
ground beef unseasonable okay so when
okay i would like to
i would like to put this to a test i
would like to go to different taco
and hamburger restaurants and i would
like i will order plain tacos with just
meat and shell
and i want you to order plain burgers
with bun and
meat and i want to see how frequently
yours is more bland than mine
so i have to not put on the allowable
ingredients that i like
ingredients i'm talking about the
strength of the taco you're comparing
just the beefs
taste buddies we all love food around
this place you know it
we know it but sometimes you got to cut
down on the carbs sometimes you got to
cut down on the sugar
sometimes you just got to cut back in
general but why
when you cut back do you have to deprive
yourself of those delicious
treats that you love so much you don't
number one not anymore
of those being cereal right yeah we've
talked about this uh
magic spoon is what we're talking about
magic spoon comes
in am i wrong no it's a zero grams of
sugar cereal
it's got 13 to 14 grams of protein in
each serving
and it's only got four net grams of
carbs
in each serving of the cereal yeah what
else does it have let's see
it's only 140 calories per serving uh
it's keto friendly gluten-free
grain-free soy free low-carb
and gmo free that's a lot of freeze a
lot of stuff you're getting free there
they're not going to charge you for the
gluten they're not going to charge you
for the grain
they're not charging you for the soy all
free sorry
edit and we've got some exciting news
magic spoon is
relaunching the blueberry flavor one of
the favorite flavors that was it was out
of stock and now it's back in stock
people
it was sold out you couldn't get it that
was my favorite one of all the ones that
i used did you have a mix
because i like mixing did you ever take
the chocolate and the peanut butter and
then make chocolate peanut butter you
know i'm not a wild guy like that
i try to keep it you know i keep
everything in its own lane
i don't love chocolate cereals as you
know i know but when i mix the chocolate
and the peanut butter together it made a
nice
midday treat i'll tell you this the
blueberry so delicious
didn't need to be mixed that's it and
that's it if you're listening from
canada magic spoon now ships there as
well and you can also build your own box
don't forget uh there's available
flavors to build your very own
custom bundle uh and those flavors are
cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter and
cinnamon so i guess then in
oh okay so you could build a bundle of
those sure you can't mix it into this
mixing frosted with your cinnamon all
right we're not getting we haven't gone
there yet it's magic spoon it's not
miracle spoon
it's only a matter of time go to
magicspoon.com tastebuds to grab
some blueberry or a custom bundle of
cereal we'll try it today
and be sure to use our promo code
tastebuds at checkout to save five
dollars off your first order this offer
is now good anywhere in the us or canada
as we mentioned
but only when you use our code at
checkout that's right
magicspoon.com tastebuds use promo code
tastebuds save yourself five bucks off
your first order
take it easy so i know a lot of us
like to indulge but a lot of us also
like to get our lives back on track and
and try to
try to live in in a somewhat healthy way
right you know a balanced way i should
say yeah
and it's very hard to do what are you
getting at noom
how'd you know because i know what
noom's all about all right i was going
to do a little more of a lead-in but you
know what you're right let's just get
now because actually
get to the good thing these people are
doing it new our good friend chris uses
noom swizz bite all the time and i'm
about to start using it too because i
i want to take my my weight and my
healthy eating more seriously it's not
about what you just ate with noon but
it's how you eat in general
teaches you about eating about your
cravings about building new habits it's
an
app and and you can ditch your your
misconceptions and get smart about the
food choice you make you're educating
yourself that's what i like
is that it's not uh you know it's not
some sort of fix all diet it's not some
sort of miracle thing it's a lifestyle
change it teaches you to recondition
yourself and to change your habits for
the better overall
and really lose weight in the effective
way yeah and you pick the health goals
that are right for you so you tailor
kind of what you're eating and then noon
personalized the weight loss program to
help your aspirations become reality so
it really is a tailored uh app that
really
you know it's unique to every person and
that's how it's different too it's not
some
it's not the same across the board well
i like that it's got many benefits it's
you know eating better to feel better
and understanding your cravings and
knowing how to shop it's uh having more
energy because you're doing this
enjoying exercise again fitting into
better clothes
it's feeling good about your choices
after all that improving
your sense of self-worth your your mood
and not being stressed
and it's easy it works with your
lifestyle you don't have to commit to
some rigorous plan
so you know i don't know i like that
it's based in psychology
and i like that it teaches you to make
the choices you do and gives you the
tool to replace your habits
with healthier ones and it takes about
10 minutes a day everyone's busy uh it
doesn't demand much of your time that's
it
80 percent of numerous finish the
program and over 60 percent have stuck
with their goals for over a year
so that's basically it you want to deal
with us is that what you want
the science to getting healthier it's
good as if this wasn't a good enough
deal already
here's what you got to do sign up for
noom through us okay a trial starts
today just go to noom n-o-o-m.com
taste bud that's n-o-o-m
dot com slash taste bud ready to learn
how to live healthy sign up for noom
today at
noom.com taste bud noom
um beefs the chickens the porks the
everythings
i'm saying the taco is so strong with
just its foundation
meat and then you start getting
taco i mean sure you could say not to
mention you could do a soft or a hard
shell
you could have you're saying but taco
like you should really be committing to
the beef taco versus the hamburger in a
way
no i shouldn't no i shouldn't we said
tacos for sure it could be like
grilled chicken sandwiches you could
also say a bacon cheeseburger you could
also say
a ham a cheeseburger with ham on it
which i've done many times
you could say a barbecue cheeseburger
you know you could you could make a lot
of arguments that's right
barbecue i got a i got an open grill i'm
alone
i'm i'm not i'm throwing a party yeah i
got a pool raging
it's a beautiful summer day i'm going
everybody
what does everybody want to eat right
right before my
right before someone we know there's a
cannonball into the pool you're thinking
they're like can you throw tacos on
there
no they're gonna be like burgers because
you can't cook tacos on a grill so
now my point of though is that dude
people crave
want and look forward to it
you're going to tell me let me get going
get this straight
you light up a burger in the summer next
door you let it
seriously you light up a grill next to a
pool in the summer you got people in the
sun that are sun stroked in the water
that are starving to death you say you
say what do you guys want to eat and
they don't go
post do that and they don't come you say
you show
starving you say you say what do you
want to eat and they don't go
spaghetti of course they don't they want
the fastest thing you can get them
they see a grill and they go a burger
will happen quickest all right there's
not
you know what if you go and by the way
if you're cooking burgers and you go
dogs are up those dogs go in two seconds
because these people let me let me take
something you think is a positive and
flip it on its ass
for you there's a taco night
right people like oh taco night let's
taco night and homes
in bars taco nights
do you know why it's there's a taco
night because it's awesome
tacos every day it's a once in a while
type you're insane
you think people are gonna put me you
don't know why you wanna you want you
know what there's no burgers
people are eating burgers way more than
once in a blue moon which by the way i
just googled the other day
is literal in literal translations every
two to three years okay
how often during the week do you eat
burgers
every given week how often well nowadays
no every given week well nowadays over
the last year
nowadays i don't eat burgers the way i
used to over the last year
yeah nowadays i don't eat burgers
right the way i used to i'll have a
burger a month now maybe two a month
right why is that was that because i'm
trying to eat a little bit healthier oh
really
really yeah you really you don't want
the greasy slab on top of
it's delicious processed wheat roll he's
talking about sugary ketchup
i tacos once a week even as part of a
healthy diet
wild child why because why why is that a
bread because it's a tortilla made from
corn
it's like i can get fresh ground meat
with with very little fat in it
i season it i put produce on it i put
good cheese on it
and boom that's a healthy meal these
words these that's a healthy meal baby
that's a salad nothing
that's a salad babe talked about you you
just talked about
making a taco yeah yeah and it's a
healthy meal
we're wearing a burger sour cream a
burger
i don't put sour cream on sometimes if i
want to be healthier i don't use stop me
yeah you get a 95 percent uh lean
burgers and tacos
have almost the same ingredients no and
you're telling me that
for one thing bad food for one thing the
bun will always be your achilles heel
with a burger
always it will always work because it's
one of the best ingredients it will
always make the burger unhealthy
so we're talking about health i don't
get what
i mean if you go down to every episode
we've ever had
if this food is not if this food is so
great that you can eat it
every day as you just said unlike tacos
i didn't say it every day well why can't
you you know it's not a burger because
everything's
not a burger night because people aren't
waiting once in a while to eat a burger
yeah
i'll tell you what never mind nobody
gives a rat let's go that's
taco night is a treat it's like pizza
night
it's like pizza nights nobody gives a
[ __ ] about burgers
what kind of stuff is that i i led this
i led this debate
by giving praise to tacos and giving all
the good attributes tacos i love it
you know i love burgers but but your
arguments are weak
your arguments are bad you think you're
gonna get under my skin with that you're
wild
you're a wild child that he's talking
where are we at time wise no
30 minutes listen to me good we're
making good time people
never mind me nowadays no no joe let me
say something all right i'm sorry i'm
sorry you've talked so much
so talk no no you talk too i'm saying
don't make it sound like i haven't let
you say anything
all i'm saying is that the reason that
burgers don't exist
is because people eat burgers like every
day like like never mind me right now if
you go back to me five years 10 years 20
years 30 years
childhood me 20 year old me late teen me
even 30s me
okay fast food was in my rotation i
would drive i would go i'd get a burger
burger's a lot more than i had now you
can't judge me america on burger king
we're not talking judges as a whole okay
we're not talking fast food though we're
not talking faster we're talking burgers
the average american eats a burger i bet
you at least
four times a month put a pin in that
before you make a second point let me
maybe more let me respond to this point
please
you started this entire debate with
saying nothing will ever beat pizza
okay it won't there's a pizza night
there's a pizza night and it's not
because oh you can only eat pizza once
in a while
it's because pizza is an awesome dream
that you want to celebrate over the
course of a night
i will not let you down you got to let
me finish my point sorry
let me finish my point i'm making a
counterpoint to your point okay
and here's my point you're making it
sound like burgers are
so much better because uh because no
they're not special that's not that's
why there's not a burger knife because
you can get one on every corner
whenever you feel like it you could go
into any 7-eleven you get a burger on
every corner and they're not special
why are they not available on every
corner because they are one of the most
popular foods in the world why
because they get on every corner pine
cones
they're not special sal joe they're not
where are you right now you cannot get
pine cones on every corner
you can't you don't know where i go i'll
go to the i'll go to the nearest corner
i'll go to the nearest corner right now
out here there's no pine cones
not on this island yeah no of course not
again
you just said out loud this sentence
that you can get a pine cone on every
single right it couldn't by chance but
hyperbole
because that's what we deal with as
comedians and podcasters the most
popular foods in the world pizza pasta
hamburger
all right i want to go through pizza
pasta hamburger soup salad bread rice
eggs it's not even on that tacos it's
not even on there let's see
winch but let's not see who wins
oh look the white baby said burgers are
better
what a surprise look at me don't compare
pizza tonight to taco night pizza nice
every friday for the world taco nights
every tuesday
taco tuesdays it's a thing dude it's not
every tuesday yes it is
no it's not it's attached to a tuesday
because they needed alliteration
because tacos needed to attach it away
[Music]
of a [ __ ] when we went away on two
vacations we had a not only did we have
a taco night yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i
was eating we had it
it was an ice cream we had it we had it
on both
trips we had a huge taco night only
everybody knows
you know what a big group tacos is a fun
night you you pick it you're like
okay
we have burgers [ __ ] how many times we
have burgers [ __ ]
i'm telling you how many we had him once
on each trip
as an afterthought when everybody was
two tired
[Music]
swear to christ if you have a little
time on your hands in a backyard and a
pool or you go over someone's house stop
saying go to the pool it's the only
thing you can cook
stop making it sound like you can make
shrimp scampi next to a pool
in the summertime a burger is a legit
option
every single night tacos are not the
reason that we had a taco night
one day out of the week is because you
try to think of fun little women
everyone likes to put them
it's a nice meal that feeds a lot of
people that's easy to make each
shrimp shall each trade
can we talk meat for once for
yeah for i mean let's i mean i'll talk
meat all day long
it's i love meat i do and i love quality
meat and it's hard to find a hundred
percent
grass-fed finished uh beefs it's
it's hard to find free-range organic
chicken sometimes it's hard to find
heritage breed pork
and sometimes it's really hard just to
find like wild caught salmon
at a grocery store and when you do find
them
they can be wildly no pun intended
overpriced luckily we got ourselves a
new sponsor and that sponsor goes by the
name of
butcherbox i love these guys
butcherbox believes everyone deserves
high quality humanely sourced meat
and when you sign up now you get a free
essentials bundle in your first box
three pounds of chicken breast two
pounds of pork chops
and two pounds of ground beef all for
free
in your first box every month butcher
box ships a curated selection of high
quality meats
right to your home it's a no-brainer
really options like what you said
100 grass-fed and finished beef free uh
range or not free chicken but free-range
organic chicken heritage pork
they let the chickens go wherever the
chickens want to go it's free range
it's a beautiful thing wild the salmon
you got to see when we come up with a
salmon they just slap at each other
they're wild
by the way one of my favorite meats they
offer sugar-free
and nitrate-free bacon which makes bacon
okay to eat
okay it's it's the it's the nitrates and
the sugar that that ruin bacon
so anyway you're gonna go to
butcherbox.com
taste buds that's butcherbox.com taste
buds
and you're gonna get a free essentials
bundle in your first box
butcherbox.com taste buds get yourself a
free essentials bundle
included with your first bite and for a
limited time they're offering the new
members that free essentials bundle
and that's three pounds of chicken
breast two pounds of pork chop
two pounds of ground beef all for free
in your first box go to butcherbox.com
tastebuds what's up taste buddies i'm
here to talk to you a little bit about
babel
babel is one of our sponsors that has a
language learning app that i've been
using
uh i don't know if you like me i grew up
uh
i live with my grandparents when i grew
up and they were spanish
and i like desperately wanted to learn
spanish and telemundo wasn't doing it
and i took it in high school
and i've since forgotten everything so
i've been trying to refresh so
babbles and perfect for me uh i
downloaded i have it with me all the
time
it's really cool like it's 15 minute
lessons that you could take on the go
um and it's good if you're looking to
learn a language in a deeper way connect
with family or you're just traveling you
could use it they're like bite-sized
language lessons
another way i use it is when i go to get
a pedicure
a lot of times the people doing the
pedicure don't speak english and i
believe that they're talking about me i
believe this was a seinfeld episode
and so i take babel with me and then i
can unearth and uncover
all the negative things they're saying
about me and the and
that i have no integrity that i eat like
a goddamn horse
that i don't tip well i learned all
these things that they were saying about
me
by using my babble app and you can too
don't ever get a pedicure
again without knowing how they're
disparaging you
uh right now when you purchase three
months of babble come on a three month
subscription they're getting you
three months free on top of it six
months for the price of three
just go to babel.com use the promo code
taste buds
by the way where is joe today he's off
right now getting hypnotized that's a
story for another episode
so anyway it's babble.com use the promo
code taste buds that's b-a-b-b-e-l.com
codetastebuzz for an extra three months
free babble
language for life now you're lying the
only time we had burgers on either trip
was the same night we had hot dogs and
both times it was the last thing we ate
because
everybody was tuckered out and tired and
nobody felt like doing anything in the
landscape
let's make the trash food on the last
night
dude burgers are served in michelin star
restaurants you're calling your treasure
maybe nah not too much really oh i
really like scales
you know also served in michelin star
restaurants this is a fact some missiles
are
they serve ants what are we arguing here
what are we arguing here i don't know
bobby kelly bobby kelly told me about a
michelin star restaurant he went to
overseas where they put ants on the
on the plate okay let me say that
sentence over that's true
let me say the sentence over
in general more restaurants
of all levels from fast food
to gourmet restaurants have said that
there's
a burger on the menu you can get a
burger
that is off a your backyard grill you
can get a burger that
is a dollar fifty of a dollar menu or
you can get a 26 dollar burger from a
place like that it doesn't matter a
burger is always delicious
go down to austin texas and see how many
gourmet taco stands there are there's a
lot
there's a lot there are endless ways to
have a burger tacos are messy
are we going to the phone messy how
about that let's go tacos are messy you
know what only if you don't know how to
do it
i always have high hopes oh yeah because
birthdays his burgers are so clean
the food that they literally they
literally had to craft a paper
wrapper to sit around the bottom of
because so much [ __ ] drops out of the
bottom
when you drive around with it i have
never i can't even
taco i have never eaten a taco in my
life
in my life i've never eaten a taco that
hasn't fallen apart all over the place
that i end up
picking up with a fork or most likely my
fingers
in little pieces at the end of sure
never the most awesome you know what
taco always fools me it always fools the
emotion everybody lays everything out
sometimes
i pick up a taco shell and it cracks
into my hand before i apply any food to
it because you don't know how to handle
it
because you don't know how to handle it
and then you take a half a taco and you
just use it as a [ __ ] because you
don't know how to handle it buddy
you're a brute no you're a brute i say
this i inherently
need it i say this i say this with the
cause
due respect i said it's all due to
respect you're a stupid brute and you
have no clue
that's crazy
you [ __ ] listen to me i have never i
have never have you ever eaten a taco
all the way through that didn't crumble
into a billion pizzas
you take the first the plate
let me talk now you have a taco night
everything's all over the table you
reach so delicately
because if you take a taco shell with
any with
any amount of pressure the thing is
[ __ ] splitting in half and it's
rendering it useless okay so you pick it
up
all dainty and you have all these high
hopes you put your thing in
you put that thing in your next layering
next thing you're in now you have it
right in the plate right just pick it up
you pick up this now it's a little
weight in there right
and now you're a little nervous because
you got to hold it a little harder and
so you feel the two taco edges they're
bending
in toward each other because there's
more weight on it so you have to squeeze
heavier right so you
what you do is you put your hands
traditionally this is like arguing a
lettuce wrap burger is messier than with
the food
yeah of course it is a quintessential
cheeseburger i think of a patty
with american cheese lettuce tomato
onion ketchup on a bun when i think of a
taco i think of a hard shell taco with
ground beef in it
lettuce cheese sour cream olives
oh well tomatoes that's what i think i i
don't know when i think of a traditional
taco i think of a soft corn tortilla
with meat onion and cilantro because
that's how the tradition is terrific
the problems that hard tacos have that
will never go away
the taco community and the taco chefs
and the tacos and the problems that
burgers have
where squirts down on your pants and get
pink juice on yourself
and the bun turns pink oh my god that's
one of the reasons i don't go to burger
joints anymore because of the squirting
of the pink juice on my pants
all right let's go listen to me let's go
listen to me no let's not go
i want to go to the throne i would love
to finish my point
have you ever eaten through a taco from
end to end
i'll give you another one i have never
taken
us after the first bite of a taco
it does not stay together you take the
first bite the shell is not staying
whole as a u-shape no one has ever eaten
a taco a hard taco
all the way through you take a bite the
whole thing cracks it falls into your
plate
and then you just take chips and you end
up eating nachos because the
taco does not stay together it's
annoying and every time i'm like this is
gonna be my dad
this is gonna be my night i'm gonna eat
a taco all the way through with no mess
it's gonna stay together i try to bite
it like in a way i put the taco down i
hold it on the bottom i give it all the
support
i try to bite it in a way where i i
really give support all the way around
with my hands
and my my digits and i bite it slowly
so that if i understand you don't know
how to eat a taco i don't know what to
tell you
taco shell right uh taco shell yeah i
want to see a bite mark out of it
rest whole i've never seen it in my life
the second you even your tooth
touches the taco shell it just implodes
into the plate and then you just eat it
with a fork
okay let's just say let's just say what
you were saying is what's this
hold on let's just say what you're
saying is true
let's just say what you're saying is
true it's one type of taco
i've argued the soft corn tortilla many
times in this debate
i will now argue the flour tortilla you
can't say
that because you've had problems with a
certain type of hard shell taco
and by the way depends on what brand
you're buying
okay blue corn versus yellow corn makes
a difference too
hate to break it to you but it does okay
but my point is
it's just a different consistency i
don't know i don't it just does so what
are you saying
the they're depending on the brain which
one which one doesn't break when you eat
it
i find that a blue corn tortilla holds
together a bit better but
is it what is a bit better well i also
find that the uh that the ortega
uh shells hold together better than the
old el paso's
how about this they had to remake the
shell recently they started remaking
them as boats
because people complained so much about
the traditional taco shell so now they
make these little tortilla platters
like these corn chips
properly my point is this what my point
is this
it doesn't matter i could argue all day
long me and you on a road trip
i we're on route 66. let me finish my
point
let me finish my point i could argue all
day long that burgers are messy
i could go you know the problem is when
you get a burger with cheese sauce on it
an extra mayo
it drips everywhere you could argue all
day long
burger's
viewers whatever the hell you want to
call yourselves god bless you though
send us a video make a taco in a hard
shell blue corn white color
get the best show arguing one type of
taco feel yourself and i want to know
i want you to take two bites i want you
to get that
how you're arguing can i speak
you're arguing one type of taco i'm not
disagreeing that a hard shell taco can
be problematic
people don't know how to eat them no i
said it yeah
the the boats yeah that that is what i
said not the boats
depending on the brand of hard shell you
buy but it doesn't matter
there are other types of tacos arguing
with one of the things that i think the
taco industry has
ignored for two taco industry would say
that hard shell tacos don't even count
because they're not traditional tacos
i don't think the industry would say
that they're making tons of money off
the hard shell
they have nerves they have so my point
is this is you want to talk i'm just
asking
i'm just saying you're saying this is
like if i argued anybody send me a video
of you taking care of more than an
interview taco and it not exploded
an intern an intern uh anybody send me a
video
of the burger where the bun is two
grilled cheese sandwiches with extra
bacon and and uh
egg on it and show me eating that
without it being messy this is my point
you can anything can be messy no but
you're acting like that's the definitive
thing
if you put enough stuff on a burger it
can get messy any
any hard shell taco is going to fall
apart
no that's not true yes it is that's not
true give me the video that's true i
want someone to take two bites out of a
hard shell taco
that doesn't fall apart show me someone
eating a taco
okay and then show me and then
immediately and then show me soft shell
tacos that never fall apart
we're talking about tacos we're not
talking hardship
one of the main issues i've had for
decades with one type of
taco i know a lot of people i prefer
hard shell
so every time i've ever indulged in
tacos which i like the taste of
i also i'm like god damn it every time
i feel like i'm gonna get through a taco
but you're talking about one type of
taco i know i'm making it if i was
arguing a lettuce wrap burger that
doesn't define
burgers it does it's a type of burger
just arguing a single point
of a strike against tacos it's it's it's
such a tiny strike
also by the bye and also i got news for
you
people like with hard shell tacos
scooping the [ __ ] off the plate that's
half good
it's like the cereal milk i got news for
you so also
a taco i feel like also is like
the same taste over and over and over i
think you can get more variation in a
burger i really do
i really do i really think a burger is
really strong in the fact that
despite it being meat and bread and then
other items i can bite into ten
different burgers and still
feel like i'm really having a different
meal if the burger's prepared
differently
but like a lot of times like even with
mexican food as a whole
it feels like a lot of the same
ingredients were purposed i think
actually
gaffigan has a bit on it because it's
very true it just feels like
it's just a lot of the same main
components not talking about mexicans
we're talking about tacos so if you want
to say you can you can have a different
type of burger every time that it's
ground meat
but somebody else cooked it i could say
i could have a pork taco you can't have
a pork burger i could have a chicken
taco you can't have a chicken burger
i could have a ground beef i could have
a ground meat taco you can't have a
ground meat burger they're all seasoned
you're changing the protein i could have
a steak
taco you can't have a steak burger you
can have protein i could okay
then let's just say just steak let's
just take steak i could have a hard
shell steak taco with lettuce tomato uh
uh maybe some onion maybe some uh
shredded sharp cheese
i could have a steak soft taco with just
onion i could have steak soft taco with
guacamole i can have a steak sauce
it's like five ingredients though and
that's it with sour cream
i could have a steak taco with four to
five different
types of hot sauces that have different
flavors i mean come on man what are we
talking about here
look i thought i i i told you at the top
of this i think tacos are great
i think burgers are great there's no way
tacos are beating burgers and i think
that you know that knives
go to the phone if i'm looking past your
specs there i see it in your eyes
let's go to the phones let's go to the
phones
with the burger you know what you're
getting whatever wherever you are in the
world oh that's always a good sign
the same can't be said about a taco if
you ask for a taco in the uk you would
get
the stalis old el paso hard shell that
cuts up your teeth making sure that
so so this person's argument is because
people don't know how to prepare the
food correctly
it's a bad thing i can already hear joe
arguing about the versatility
of the taco grow up you can't grill a
taco
grill taco
proved that you could grill a taco by
the way i was wrong burgers are tops for
me i prefer burgers wearing tacos but
i'll have tacos if i feel
that's what i'll eat i guess burgers are
easier to handle than tacos
and they don't make such a mess well
again this is one type of taco
tacos are better if you're going to the
right places burgers at fast food places
are done better
than fast food well of course fast food
tacos except for taco bell
and el uh uh del taco or you know i mean
jack in the box puts american cheese on
them it's disgusting
a burger will put you in a nice
retirement home when you're old the taco
would steal you
well that's racist
[Laughter]
that's nothing to erase both are great
when freshly made but hard shell tacos
are
trash after a few minutes there you go
look the comments are agreeing with you
you might win this thing
i mean that could it could be good
though oh wait that's a response sorry
damn this one's not even fair it's like
asking which are your children you love
the most
i'm gonna have to go tacos on this one
there are so many kinds fish tacos pork
chocos beef
thank you plus a good taco really sets
itself apart for the rest a good
hamburger really isn't different than an
okay burger
that's not true at all if sal is team
burger joe isn't gonna let him say
he likes anything on his burger because
that would be changing the food
i did the job in taco salad mini tacos
and probably burritos and even wouldn't
be surprised if he said chocolate
i said choco tacos it's a taco is it not
i didn't say burritos or any of that
other [ __ ] though
burgers are america as far as i'm
concerned
tacos are fabulous too not that i can
eat either because i am lonely i'm a
lonely store mannequin
okay okay burgers can be taco flavored
tacos cannot be burnt not true i make i
make bacon cheeseburger tacos all the
time
my birthday is tomorrow would be nice to
get oh jesus christ uh
everyone who said burgers you're wrong
thank you sarah there's only one real
taco fast food place and that is the
scum
[Laughter]
burgers are the cornerstone that you got
to read them because our viewers don't
know burgers are the cornerstone of
america that's my favorite
there's only one real taco fast food
place in that and that is the scum that
is taco bell
burgers are the cornerstone of america
that's my favorite i see people are
saying the americana so i was on point
there
i could eat tacos all day every day but
i have to be in the mood for a burger
that's how i feel in reverse
that's how i feel reverse imagine going
into a bar and asking for a taco yeah
i've done it several times actually
i'll take it off american cheeseburger
with bacon any day
all right i mean this is very very close
actually tacos are their own
no it's not you're creaming me right
really tacos scroll back out mike tacos
their own damn day for god's sakes what
do burgers have taco tuesday that's
that's your side and that's a
tenderloins fan uh taco tuesday by the
way
is not every tuesday i just wanted to
make that point before because you said
they have pizza night
pizza night is like one of them tonight
was every once a week every friday i
know but like
tacos is not every tuesday taco tuesday
many households i'm familiar with
it's every tuesday it's taco tuesday
with the kids you don't think that
that's just a restaurant
being like oh it's i've never seen it in
a restaurant i've seen my friends
families do it
really yes i i really believe that like
everyone knows
people eat pizza once a week a minimum
people eat have taco night like once in
a while so
you saying that there's a pizza night
and comparing it to a taco night
is insane how many times you're not
insane
how many times you have a pizza night
versus a taco night it's not crazy
taco night is dude listen hold on
there's a family
there's gonna be some fairness once
every week
there's gotta be two months there's
tonight's once a week but hold on a
second
there's got to be some fairness to
saying okay and i don't mean this is
cast aspersions
there's got to be some fears to say you
live in staten island sure
a heavily italian population just moved
to go to new york city what i'm saying
though i'm saying like
you don't think it's a coincidence you
think it's just coincidence that you
guys had pizza night more frequently
here than taco night
i mean just say let's say manhattan that
you're it's it's your exactly
it's your exact argument before about
mexico if i went to mexico and i was
like
they never have pizza night down here i
mean come on no but you're saying taco
is every tuesday and that's not true
it's just that he is
it goes well with it where i come from
taco tuesdays were a thing
that's where i come from all right both
are pretty messy but burgers are just
better tacos fall apart and leave a huge
mess
it's more difficult to keep them
together than a burger also burgers
don't leave you on the toilet
for 20 minutes i didn't even touch upon
the toilet
you what i didn't even touch upon the
toilet oh stop it
toilet tuesdays toilet tuesdays that's
an old wives tale so let's go to the
vote oh my god is that right
we didn't see burgers oh no that was one
of the fake tweets okay ready
pimp give it to us
where do you think what do you think
isn't that now what do you think this is
meant now i think burgers is going to
win but i think
tacos might show a better fight than you
think it's give me this give me the
give me the the the uh say burger's
going to win by 10
okay you think it's going to be a you
think it's going to be like 66. i think
you're going to win but i don't know
55.45 you think it's going to be
something like that or maybe a 60 40. i
don't think you're going to win by
atlanta
here we go
65-35 which is a landslide
that's where it starts to become a
pretty big drubbing okay i know
i know that word i do love the word 30
on that all right 30
yeah that's big baby good work big
good work
just i'm just saying berg is 65.1
percent
to 34.9 percent after 16 000 plus votes
wow it's big babe that's big i just
didn't know we lived in such a
close-minded country
i will say i thought burgers was the
front runner
and so i'm not surprised but i thought
burgers would win but not by that much
same same not by that much that's
a lot man yeah but dude you're dealing
with i think it's pizza
burgers name the number two food at the
pizza
i mean you gotta i just love tacos so
much
i know we know that about you now i love
tacos so much
and in this health conscious crazy cold
top
hold on let me stop making believe taco
is healthy i didn't say that let me
finish
in this health conscious crazy culture
we live in people all the time are
eating like
cauliflower tacos and kale tacos and all
these things that you can't really do
with burgers
it's like a veggie burger or nothing
what do you mean they have the like
impossible burger in the veggie
what do you mean that's their version of
it i've even had cauliflower pizza
have it all the time we're not talking
about peach fine all right
health conscious you kept saying health
conscious with tacos i'm the healthiest
snack
if you go if you if you said to somebody
i got to eat a little healthier today
they would pick that they would pick the
taco please fish taco maybe 100
they'd pick the taco place over the
burger not necessarily a beef taco
though
i didn't say a beef top i never said
these things you're saying i'm saying
i'm saying i'm saying
to you all i know is that in this
culture i'm surprised
the tacos didn't win that's what i'm
saying okay
because i find that it with the
versatility and with the vegetarian
options and all these other things with
tacos
it's it's very popular food amongst
people well i still love you
i love you too that's our show folks
we'll see you next time yeah we gotta we
weren't doing
we doing any plugs all right
yeah i might let it go
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate
talking about the food they like two
fools gonna fight but only one food can
be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds